there are numerous factors that have
contributed to Africa's economic develop
economic development issues I have
decided specifically to focus on one of
those which is basically policy however
in the book I do talk about things like
the historical context issues of
geography the historical context and the
contents of colonialism for example and
how that all may have to some extent
contributed to the economic malaise that
we see now across the continent
however the main issue that I am
tackling in my work is that of aid which
is an active policy where we as the
international and global community have
designed a specific policy towards
towards supporting economic development
in Africa so rather than things like
geography and history which are
ostensibly outside the realm of our
abilities were really focused on a very
specific issue of aid to Africa and how
that has been a negative factor in
ensuring long-term economic growth
I suppose in the context of my work I
think that there is this unstated view
or unstated fact that a to Africa has
not worked by that I should clarify that
there are essentially three types of aid
there's a humanitarian or emergency aid
which goes to actually assist during
times of let's say a tsunami or if
there's a an emergency like an
earthquake or a flood then there's also
NGO or charitable aid which is very
small amounts of money that people send
to African countries to support pretty
much clear and defined projects such as
providing a scholarship for a girl to go
to school those two types of aid that
I've just mentioned are they can
certainly help in terms of immediate
band-aid solution solutions but they
will not contribute to long-term
economic development in the sense that
it will not help to get Africa to grow
at sort of ten percent or more per year
which would actually meaningfully reduce
poverty across the continent but so
those two types of aid are very
different from the third type of aid
which is what I critique in the book
which is the large billion dollar
programs of aid that go from government
to governments and also international
institutions such as the World Bank to
Africa and those are that's the type of
aid that I'm talking about
the history of aid in Africa or in the
development discourse has its roots and
actually began in earnest in the at the
Bretton Woods in the 1940s and
essentially really took hold
after the Marshall Plan which was in the
night between 1945 and 1919 fifty
there's a five-year program
it was thirteen billion dollars which in
today's terms is about a hundred billion
dollars and really the idea was that the
newly emerging African countries that
were coming out of Independence had no
money to finance economic development so
the idea is very simple that savings
leads to investment which would lead to
growth the problem is that because these
were new economies there was not
necessarily any savings in these
economies and so the idea was that you
put aid instead of the savings and aid
should lead to investment and therefore
lead to growth what we have seen
actually is that that has not been the
case the issue of of aid delivering
growth and reducing poverty has not
actually happened in reality if anything
we've seen growth rates go down across
Africa and poverty rate levels rise very
dramatically while at the same time Aid
has consistently risen over time in
Africa I should add here that one of the
fundamental problems with the aid model
is that we've tried many different
interventions so in the 1960s aid was
very focused on infrastructure that
didn't work so the decision was to move
towards aid for poverty that didn't
really work in alleviating poverty went
to the 1980s where we focused on aid for
structure adjustment and stabilization
that also did not deliver the the growth
that we would like to see we went to the
1990s which is focusing on aid for for
democracy and governance issues again
that did not work efficiently so we've
ended up in the 2000s where there seems
to be a focus on what I call glamour aid
so the role of celebrities and in
champion and aid aid causes rather than
there being a real economic policy
there are many many reasons why aid to
Africa does not work the the government
the government that I'm referring to the
most obvious one that many people will
be very familiar with is the idea that
this money going into Africa's is
ostensibly free in the sense that
there's no constraints on how
governments on the ground use the money
and so it's very easily corrupted and in
fact we've got a long history across the
continent of a lot of the money that has
gone into Africa being stolen and
diverted for non-productive uses so
corruption is is an obvious one however
there are many many other reasons why
giving or sending billion-dollar
packages in the form of US dollars for
example into small economies is very
harmful for example you can see why
having that kind of money flying into a
country makes the government less
inclined to raise money through other
sources of capital because they have
this steady flow of permanent income
what they perceive is permanent income
coming in the government develops what I
would call a lazy muscle and this can
breed dependency which means that the
government's are not focused on actually
building up other sources of capital
such as the private sector which is
important for growth things like
inflation things like Dutch disease
where basically the domestic or the poor
countries export sector gets killed off
because there's so much money coming in
which makes the local currency very
strong versus other currencies outside
and that actually makes people not
interested in buying the food from the
poor country thence those type of things
are also very well tech documented in
the in the literature but perhaps if I
could pick one thing that is
particularly problematic with having
large flows of money going into a poor
country it would be that all this aid
actually disenfranchises Africans
Africans on the ground cannot hold their
governments accountable in the most
effective way why because African
governments because of the nature of the
system spend an inordinate amount of
I'm courting and talking to donors about
the aid programs whereas if they behave
and as I've we talked before if the
government's behave badly there's no
recourse to that bad behavior from the
ground and we as we know from historical
instance the the donors themselves tend
to be quite lenient on bad governments
and they allow them to stay in power so
the fact that Africans are
disenfranchised means that Africans
cannot ensure that their governments
deliver on social services and public
goods like you would see in any other
country around the world in particular
it's no surprise that things like
education health care infrastructure and
even security are now being provided to
Africa from outsiders and that just
leaves the situation where the African
governments I have a questionable role
what exactly is the role for African
governments when they are not
responsible for those things
going back to my point about
accountability the whole policy
structure the cultural structure the
cultural fabric of a society that
depends on outsiders to finance it is
actually then designed and guided by the
outsider's view of what they want to see
so the example that you've given of the
former President Bush's policy to
provide HIV drugs to Africa only under
the program of abstinence or not drugs
but HIV support by the abstinence is a
very good example of how it is that it
matters less what the Africans think
about their own society because the
donors because they're giving the money
have a higher higher charge on on what
school what's going to be done with that
money
most investors are looking for
governments or looking to invest in
countries where the government has a
clear agenda of how its going to grow
the economy over a multi-year period
very often
the what's been quite clear from the
past to the historical circumstance very
often African governments do not have
much of a role in in that putting that
experience together bring those plans
together and so many investors look at
Africa and say this place must be a
basket case
because rather than really doing the
hard work so trying to finance economic
development from from other sources such
as foreign direct investment or the bond
market survey transparent the the past
tradition has been for African
governments to raise money through the
World Bank and and Maul and the
bilateral donors which is quite opaque
nobody knows you know which country is
doing better then another country
because it's all kind of closed and
information is not very clear on how
these countries are doing so this has
actually discouraged private investors
coming in moreover because of the
bureaucracy and the lack of focus or an
incentive for governments in in Africa
to try and raise money from other
sources we find that it's become so
difficult to start a business for
example in Africa for some countries it
takes up to two years to get a business
license and that's to me is an artifact
again of a system where the government
doesn't really need to find other ways
of raising money they're okay to
continue to sustain the bureaucracy
because there's there's money coming in
from from aid
well the good news is that we're seeing
a new crop of African leaders coming up
who are questioning the aid system and
recognizing that it's not such a good
system for the delivery of long-term
economic growth and the reduction of
poverty so for example at the extreme
we've got places like South Africa and
Botswana that do not rely on aid to the
extent that other African countries do
but we also have countries like Ghana
which are making strides away from aid
and towards more private capital
solutions to finance development more
recently I spent some time in Rwanda and
President of Rwanda mr. Kagame President
Kagame has been a very vocal about how
aid doesn't work and how he is
desperately trying to find ways to wean
his country off of Aid and there needs
to be much more of that but there are
African countries where we're actually
beginning to hear this dialogue it's a
great pity that many of these African
leaders who are much more innovative in
how they're looking at financing
development and reducing poverty in
their countries don't really have an
international audience we don't hear
that much from them but they have very
clear plans on what they're going to do
one of the things that very easily a
country can do for example is to look at
getting a credit rating of which only
currently only 15 out of about 50
African countries have credit ratings
and yet kriti ratings are a prerequisite
to access the international capital
market so that's just a specific example
of what I believe is a space for a lot
more improvement in in moving away from
Aid
well I think there will be definitely be
an impact in a negative one at that
because one can envisage the situation
where Westerners Western governments who
are dealing with their own crises at
home are going to be faced with
shrinking budgets and needs to borrow
more money quite aggressively so the
bailout programs that are very familiar
in the Western in the United States but
also more generally in donor countries
have become a very big deal to countries
in particular Italy has been very public
about cutting back at the eight budget
by fifty percent but also in Britain
movements in the exchange rate who have
meant that the actual notional amount of
money that they're going to be giving to
developing countries has shrunk so these
type of factors which are an artifact of
the credit crisis mean that the aid
model is really under under threat
I mean I sit on a number of charities on
the board of a number of charities that
are doing fantastic work in Africa and
I'll come into details in a moment but I
think what's really important to stress
here again is what these charities can
and cannot do
so the charities that I sit on are able
to go into these countries and actually
provide band-aid solutions intermediate
solutions they cannot provide jobs which
is where it's really important for us to
see much more involvement in the private
sector and that's why I'm talking about
this other form of aid and and why it's
it's hamper that that opportunity some
of those charities that I think are
doing some fantastic work are places
like room to read which has got very
targeted programs towards helping young
people get access to books other
charities for example I sit on the board
of a charity called London for Africa
which is a very very clearly defined
mandate to try and support it by through
lending projects in microfinance across
the continent and a third charge that I
work for or I'll who's I'm a patron for
whom I'm a patron is called arc
absolutely turned for kids again very
targeted involvement providing
antiretrovirals
to African Africans in across Africa but
again very narrow and also no illusion
that they are going to be providing long
term sustainable growth to these to
these countries so there are some
examples of some some interesting
programs
well the to the extent that we know what
we're not going to achieve those goals
which is obvious 2015's around the
corner you know the architects of the
Millennium Development Goals are
themselves going around saying that you
know Africa is likely not to meet any of
those goals
so I think those type of very sort of
large big scale large focus lofty goals
tend to me to be to be red herrings for
the fundamental issues what I'm looking
to see is much more active programs to
implement the things that we know work
the things that have made China China
and India and South Africa and Botswana
successful at creating jobs and reducing
poverty that's what we need to focus our
efforts on I think it's also important
that we focus on spinning a more
positive story about Africa too many of
the NGOs and celebrities and charities
around are very focused on perpetuating
a negative stereotype about the concept
which cannot be helpful to raise the
very young Africans that are coming up
across the continent that is of no value
to be negative and yet that's what we
see across the continent so I think we
just need to do more of what we know
works and less of what we know does not
work in fact there is no country on
earth today that has achieved economic
development and reduced poverty by
relying on aid not a single one and yet
we're pushing a product that we know
doesn't work at a time when we know what
does work and that's what the issue is
here
absolutely microfinance is one of the
tools for development that I talk about
in the book it is it's an amazing
amazing way of providing support to
Africans and people all around the world
to finance them themselves and therefore
be able to stand on their own two feet
they can provide themselves with an
income provide education and health care
to their children there are numerous
examples of this Muhammad Yunus won the
Nobel Prize for Grameen Bank and I just
was so on a on a discussion of program
with him not too long ago even in this
market he's you know with all the the
challenges of the capital markets right
now he's managed to raise 1 billion
dollars from the very small aid commit
student in very small communities within
Bangladesh it's a billion dollars in
rural Bangladesh and you know very very
low default rates and you know
tremendous success these are the type of
programs that should be coming out of
the multilateral institutions and
they're not we're seeing more of the
same giving more money to African
governments giving the money to
governments around the world whereas it
seems to me we know what works and Kiva
is another example I talked about in the
book it's an internet interface 420
minimum of $25 you can lend to an
entrepreneur anywhere around the world
again helping to finance a job and again
lending is the operative world word
gives an opportunity for African
Africans on the grounds to actually
meaningfully change their lives
on the point of corruption the problem
is that it makes good governments bad
and bad governments worse and how does
that happen is boils down to incentives
it doesn't matter where you are on this
earth if you live in New York or in
London or in anywhere in Africa we're
all driven by incentives governments are
incentivized as are individuals and our
societies as a whole as a whole the
problem with Aid which is essentially
giving free money to somebody with no
recourse means that the incentive
structure it introduces a very negative
Institute incentive structure you can
steal that money and have no recourse
you can use that money for
non-productive activities and there's no
penalty there's no punishment you don't
lose office you don't end up in jail and
because of that what in economics is
call there's a rent without you know
when you can have you cannot have rent
seeking which is the economic term for
corruption or graft you cannot have rent
seeking without a rent and unfortunately
aid provides that rent in the context of
many African countries and is a very
easy thing to steal
I don't think in in the African context
you can separate the aid model from the
political leadership that we have the
good African leaders that we do have
across Africa is are actually because
they themselves have a moral qualms to
actually do what's right what I mean by
that is it's all too easy if you are a
good leader to become bad and the bad
leader to become worse so there's a
reason why African history is littered
with examples of despotic and tyrannical
you know leaders across the continent
who've stayed in power for many many
years and you know even in those
situations they have very clearly
continued to receive aid monies I wish I
could sit here and say actually this is
a figment of the past it's not there's
still many African leaders that are
still facing charges you know very
regularly most recently we were still
hearing of governments that are actually
being sued for stealing aid money so
this is not something from the past and
I think it's virtually impossible to
strip out the aspect of political
leadership from the aid model the the
notion of lack of accountability
immediately comes in when you've got an
aid model
I think there have been a number of
Africans the debate about aid to Africa
is going on every day across the
continent unfortunately many Africans do
not have the space or the airtime to
actually be able to comment on whether
they either agree or even disagree about
the aid model I think it's it's it's
also quite interesting that it's not
just the average African who's not
getting air time it's a the political
leadership if you asked Americans to
name three African leaders or maybe even
just one African leader one African
president and you know who they could
say they knew what their view was about
where the countenance is going and how
Aid is helping or not helping they
wouldn't be able to do that because the
face of Africa is not of Africans
whether it's the average African nor is
it the face of African leadership that
that vacuum has been taken over by other
people
it's yet to be seen I think the
immediate issue is economics I'm an
economist and so my bias is towards
economics as a prerequisite to any
political system I don't think that
having spending time on issues of
democracy per se or political systems is
necessary at a time when people are
starving and dying from the failure of
the economic system and on a daily basis
I believe in my approaches we first want
to ensure that you have the economic
systems in place that people can
actually provide for themselves they can
get jobs and they're correctly
incentivized so that you can actually
build up and generate a middle class
with vested interests like anywhere else
in the world and into that middle class
that will force the government to
deliver on its promises which is like is
the way it works
anywhere else in the world including in
the United States so any conversation
about the political framework to me is
moot until you actually have an economic
a sustainable economic strategy in place
where people feel like they it's
alleviating poverty and actually
generating long term economic policy
opportunities for Africans
there is good news and this is what I
was talking about earlier we tend to
dwell on the negative things in Africa
and that's what we have we as in the
international community seem to have a
lot of appetite for that and the people
who have ostensibly become the face of
Africa seem to want to focus on the
negative aspects but let's just take a
look at what's happened in the last five
to seven years Africa now has 15 stock
markets with 500 stock exchanges
excuse me so it's 500 shares that trade
on the stock exchanges we've seen
actually improvement and infrastructure
largely because of the Chinese in Africa
we're seeing also job creation we've
seen African countries achieve and
sometimes pass 7% growth rates and even
now at the height of the credit crisis
the IMF is forecasting that Africa could
grow by about 3 and a half percent 3
between 3 and 3 and 1/2 percent this is
a time when many many countries around
the world are posting expecting to post
negative growth rates and the world as a
whole is likely to grow at around 0.5%
so there is good news
I think what the Chinese have done in
Africa in the last 10 years has been
amazing they have brought in
infrastructure where it has not existed
before and they provided jobs where
we've not been able to get jobs in in
the past 60 years overall I would say
that they've been a positive force
towards economic development in Africa
they've even diversified their approach
to Africa it initially was very heavily
dependent on the mining and mineral
sector and oil and gas they've now
become much more focused on things like
agriculture banking sectors are much
more diversified now this is not to say
that the Chinese are perfect and that
they should come to Africa carte blanche
I think that there are many issues that
the media for certainly the Western
media has picked up on and there's a lot
of scope for trying to actually improve
the discourse and the the alliances
between African countries and the
Chinese but that is not the
responsibility of the international
community to police that it's the
responsibility of African governments
were they accountable to their people to
actually ensure that the Chinese are
behaving in the best interest of Africa
so I think that there's a lot of scope
there and the think that it really boils
down again to the notion of incentives
when the Chinese come to Africa they
look at Africans as equals or at least
as business partners and and a basis
upon which to engage is all commercial
whereas when Westerners come to Africa
it's a two-tiered relationship they're
coming in as the superior donor and the
Africans are always viewed as the junior
partner or the or the the inferior
recipient
I think it's time for dramatic
innovation in Africa Africa tends to be
viewed under the guise of this what I
call the Four Horsemen of Africa's
apocalypse and the four things being war
disease poverty and corruption and
unfortunately that has meant that
Africa's been held back and suffers from
a serious negative PR problem I believe
that going forward if African focus on
building alliances with the regions of
the world who have looked past that
negative perception and are actually
looking at the continent as an
opportunity to invest and opportunity to
make to make money and to as a see
commercial enterprise grow those are the
type of alliances Africa should be
focused on for example China has 1.3
billion people seven percent arable and
it needs to feed its people
Africa's got a lot of arable land
there's obviously scope for an alliance
there whereas traditionally African
produce the agriculture produce in
particular has been locked out of the US
and European markets here's a clear
opportunity for African governments to
find a relationship with with a country
that is very interested in African
produce so that's I think that there'll
be much it should be much more of that
so much so that Africa can continue to
do a very strong solid developmental
path
um I think that there's a lot more scope
for it to be able to move the needle
towards a positive message if we start
to listen to different messengers I
think the reason why it's negative is
that the traditional media tends to
always go and interview the same kind of
people very often people who have rarely
been to Africa or maybe been to Africa a
handful of times they don't know what
it's like living there they don't have
families there they don't have not had
the experience there and so they have
not cannot pinpoint the positive aspects
of the continent there are many positive
things happening
Africa's got a female president Africa
has got as I said 15 stock markets now
it has it's shown some positive signs of
growth we're seeing some improvements in
input in the capital market growth and
so on and yet if you ask the traditional
sort of commentators on Africa the ones
who have have sort of self imposed
themselves as spokespeople for Africa
you never hear those positive stories
all you hear is the sort of tragic
stories which do exist but that cannot
be the face of Africa that cannot be the
manner in which the world expects Africa
and Africans to raise their children for
the new years to come
as I said earlier over 60% of the
population in Africa is under the age of
24 so this is a very big it's very
important to get young Africans to
believe in themselves and have a
positive outlook about themselves and
their continents and the role of their
continent in the broader scheme of the
world I do not believe that the NGOs and
the celebrities and so on that be the
ones that are really the face of the
debates thus far have really made a
concerted effort to make that message
positive
I don't think you can say we can say
that because it's important to
understand the global linkages and
perhaps allowing Lehman Brothers to fail
as an example of why you cannot make
these decisions very quickly nor can you
make them very like in a very light
manner not only do are there such close
linkages and significant linkages in
terms of size that could could really
dramatically affect or cause a collapse
of the whole banking system which would
not be a good thing were there to be a
decision to to allow some hedge funds to
fail for example or some investor to
fail so I actually don't think so I
think it's a much more it needs a much
more considered approach I know people
are very anxious and very keen to see
decisions be made quickly but I think
it's really important to understand that
we now also know that what can happen to
its system if if a bank is allowed to
spare or a big financial institution is
about to fail from the experience of
seeing Lehman Brothers fail so I
actually think that you know we would
like to see more regulation we would
like to see some changes to the system
that from where it was in the past but I
don't think that we should get too hung
up on allowing a specific hedge fund or
hedge funds to family